in this video we will talk about the
question can you train martial arts on
your own
so to answer the question quite simply
of course you can train alone the way I
see it if you want to be really good at
anything it's not so much a question of
can you train alone rather than the
statement that you must train alone if
you do the math even if you're training
at a regular facility say two to three
times a week
the ratio of time to when you're in
those classes 20 out of the classes is
still incredibly unbalanced and that's
time that you could be using to get even
better the only thing that I see there
is distinctly different about me is I'm
not afraid to die on a trip you would
not be out work now I'm sure the words
overtraining
are run in some people's mind when they
hear me say that let me state that I'm
absolutely not being facetious with that
statement at all this is what the really
really elite people are doing the real
skill development has to take place upon
your own watch and knowing that you're
doing more than your competition will
give you a massive confidence in your
abilities I liked to be a little bit
over trained yes you were tired yes I
had to come back for the second work of
the night but so what so firstly I'll be
talking about the importance of training
alone and putting those hours into your
craft and in the second part of the
video I'll be taking you through some
methods and means of what you can do
that and keep it fresh and interesting
for yourself I also just want to clarify
that and by no means saying that
training alone is superior to training
with an experienced instructor for
instance or a training partner however
what I have observed is that a person's
self belief and drive to get better is
without a doubt the biggest determining
factor that separates the elite from the
mediocre i 100% believe that you can
learn a hell of a lot more than you
probably think you can just by watching
people who are successful and then
putting into practice what you see them
doing your own training a lot of
entrepreneurs and high performers also
subscribe to this notion that the
willingness to be self sufficient and to
put in the time to get better far
outweighs any formal qualifications or
training you do on the subject now it
would be quite foolish to think it's
going to happen overnight but by
maximizing the effort that you put in
and using your time wisely you're going
to be able to accelerate the process for
yourself quite considerably and in my
experience that comes down to basically
two areas number one is doing the right
things and number two is doing them with
enough intensity when you train you can
see that with any elite athletes for
instance take this story about HESA
Rodriguez who's a football player
just sign with Real Madrid and he tells
this story about when he goes to
training for the first time I remember
the first time when I went to Real
Madrid's training I got there two hours
earlier to impress my coach but when I
got there I saw Cristiano was already
there training so it's not so much a
question of what do you have to do
rather who do you have to become to be
able to achieve the things you want to
achieve it might help you to look at
some people you admire for instance or
people who you respect so let's take
Ronaldo again for instance if you ask
the question what kind of person is
Renauld there what must his mindset be
like to become arguably the best
football player in the world for me I
think the small details in the hand
gonna make a huge difference you have to
work I try to do it almost every day
this is why I'm in the top level many
many years it's not my confidence it's
because I do it extra outside the pitch
I really believe in having a strong work
ethic and having the discipline to show
up to training even when you don't want
to because you have a goal that's
greater than your emotions in that
moment so whether your training partner
can come to training or not or whether
it flakes on you can't be an excuse that
you didn't get that 1% better than you
were yesterday so now we're going to go
to some footage of me training and I'm
gonna give you a few methods that you
can use to maximize your efficiency when
training alone one thing I almost always
warm up with is some form of shadow
boxing this is greater than when it's
down but what really helps is to perform
in front of a mirror if you've got one
available you'd be able to check that
your technique is how you think it is
and if you're making any mistakes as
well obviously watch out for things like
making sure your punches go out and come
back up on the same line your feet and
shoulders doing the right position and
your hands are raised and things like
that shadow boxing is really effective
because you don't have something to hit
so you're using things like your AB C's
back muscles much more and that's
because you have to stop the force of
the punch or the kick yourself and
maintain your balance as well
performing your moves really slowly is
probably one of the best ways to really
develop your technique for the purpose
of this demonstration I'm going to be
showing you with kicking techniques now
if you see here I'm holding onto this
wall and maps are after kata for the
balance which would take my focus away
from the actual kick itself with slow
kicking drills you can do lots of
different variations like holds slow and
fast repetitions and also combining
different kicks and doubling up kicks as
well this is something that I have
really really been getting into lately
it's the agility ladder it's a really
really cheap piece of equipment and it's
amazing for your footwork dexterity and
just overall agility and it can also get
you really fit as well depending on the
intensity level you train up I
personally feel that a lot of martial
art styles lack adequate footwork or
martial art styles have their own
benefits and different things that are
good about them but one thing I've
noticed across the board is a lot of
them do lack decent footwork or the
footwork that the employee is incredibly
basic so that's one of the reasons I'd
like to train this but it's also great
fun as well sometimes I use the leather
as a warm-up exercise as it's perfect
for getting your body nice and loose and
warm and getting a sweat on but you can
also incorporate it as a regular part of
your training if you want to go more
intense or do longer rounds I absolutely
love training on a heavy bag and it
probably makes up the majority of my
alone training actually it's important
though to make sure that you very eight
what you're doing a little bit say that
you don't stagnate and get bored because
then you'll lose interest quite quickly
so the first thing we're going to do
here is just a hands only training
session and of course you into a kicking
one as well if you like so obviously
you'll be employing your boxing
techniques in here but you can also add
elbows from Thai boxing and things like
that as well so you can see here this is
what I would call intense and fast punch
in so and point you really really
quickly here I'm not paying too much
attention to power I'm just trying to
move quickly be nice and light and stay
relaxed throughout as well and then
obviously the opposite to that you've
got hard and powerful so where you're
trying to hit the bag as hard as you can
in order to develop your power not
worrying too much about putting value on
this one I'm just trying to deliver the
maximum power that we can behind those
strikes you can also just work on one or
two simple combinations so you'll just
repeat them throughout your rounds or
you can simplify that even further and
just repeat one technique and do it from
different selves remember guys that
whatever your training whether it's
power or speed always be mindful to have
good tech
the reason being is when you start to
get tired especially your technique will
just naturally start to wane off and
then you'll be embedding bad habits into
your muscle memory which you really
don't want and I've also included an
experimental round in here which is
something I really really enjoy doing
it's just where you're experimenting
with different things not worrying too
much about what you're doing having fun
with it and trying out things and seeing
if they work remember guys that working
with a sufficient intensity level is
incredibly important the reason I say
that is I often observe people who seem
to train at the same pace and intensity
level every time they're training and
they obviously never really seem to get
any better but the most unfortunate part
is they seem to be under the illusion
that they really are doing enough to get
good however they're just simply quite
unaware of what it actually takes so
just make sure that you're not falling
victim to that obviously don't kill
yourself so that you can't train the
next day but make sure you're putting in
sufficient effort with whatever you're
doing this next one is something I do
quite often and that self videotaping my
training sessions you can do this with
anything you do whether it's heavy bag -
footwork - shadow boxing or whatever you
want it's a similar concept to shadow
box and looking in the mirror at your
technique but it's superior in the fact
that you can see yourself from all
different angles sometimes you might be
doing something in a certain way that
feels really good but then you watch
your back and you realize that you had a
big flaw in your technique if you have a
device that does it I recommend you
record in a high frame rate and that's
so that when you get it onto say editing
software or an external player that you
can really really slow it down you've
got those extra frames to check out how
you move in this can also act as a
really good motivator if you collect
those clips together in an archive and
then look back at your improvements over
time now I don't think I need to tell
you how important working out and
conditioning is to supplement with your
regular training in whatever endeavor
you're pursuing so if you're not doing
any extra work on top of your regular
training every techniques then you're
really really missing out remember that
cristiano ronaldo clip i showed earlier
where he said he believed he's still on
top of the game because he does extra
off the pitch it's exactly the same for
what we're doing so make sure you've got
a decent conditioning program whatever
that is to supplement along with your
martial arts training
now this one is a little less practical
than the others but no less important
it's more of a mental training exercise
and that's studying in great detail
somebody whose technique you admire now
when I was a little kid I used to do
this all the time I just was having fun
with it didn't really know what I was
doing but looking back in hindsight it
was probably one of the most important
things I ever did why I personally
recommend this downloading the clips
from YouTube onto your computer and then
opening them in a player so you can
study them I like to use QuickTime
Player and I'm still getting technique
because you can just pause the video and
then hit the right key to shift it along
frame by frame which is really good for
studying somebody I sometimes go one
step further with this and actually slow
down the clips using editing software
and then take them to the gym with me so
I can learn on the go while I'm training
it's a really good way of refining your
technique and also staying inspired and
motivated and getting really excited
watching those clips a good way to
improve your reaction times is to create
an audio recording of you calling out
certain numbers that correlate to
specific techniques so you're probably
aware that in boxing they use numbers 1
to 6 for all the basic boxing punches so
for instance if I was to say 6 3 2 that
would be a rear uppercut a lead hook and
a cross and you can further adapt that
with more numbers or commands for kicks
in any other techniques you want as well
the idea is to react as fast as you can
when you hear those commands without
thinking about it too much it will be
something like this 1 1 2 3 6 4 3 4 rear
leg side kick 8 straight punches 1 1 2
so you can also do this with combos as
well so for instance you might memorize
3 to 4 basic combinations that would
correlate to a number and when you hear
that number called you have to react
with the correct set of moves as fast as
you can again without thinking about it
too much
it can be helpful to keep a lock of any
training you're currently doing as well
as including pointers that you feel you
could improve on this was also something
that Bruce Lee believed in and was known
to do quite diligently this can help to
motivate us because when we start to see
results we can read back over previous
entries to see where we've improved so
the things that you can include in there
are a brief description of your workout
for that day how did you feel it went
and what could you improve on next time
it can also be really helpful to include
the description of your current diet
and/or any supplements that you taking
also I hope you enjoyed this video and
got some value from it there's just a
general overview and some ideas of
things that you can do when training
alone to keep it exciting and fresh for
yourself but also said that you don't
stagnate and repeat the same patterns
all the time with your training if you'd
like to see any of these in more detail
just let me know and I'm sure I can do a
video about that in the future for you
if you liked this video and found value
in it please subscribe to the Baniya and
follow me across all social media
platforms thank you very much for
watching and I'll see you next time